well leaders at the animal foundation
say they're experiencing a seasonal
phenomena which has the shelter close to
capacity now we're told hundreds of dogs
and cats are in dire need of a home and
to achieve that there's an offer to help
motivate nevadans to adopt
i think she's four years old and
she's in perfect health chris enter is
on the search for the perfect pet we
just lost our dog
last week and
figured the best way to cope is to get
another dog enter says his family went
to the animal foundation's website and
was overwhelmed by all the dogs and cats
needing a home it's something that
happens the same time every year
according to the animal foundation's ceo
hillary gray a lot of kittens are coming
into the shelter that have come into
being during the spring
it's people on the move it's the fourth
of july where a lot of animals get out
of their homes and not all of them are
recovered
gray tells us over 400 pets including
dogs cats and rabbits are looking for a
forever home right now she hopes
families will go above and beyond
opening their hearts and their homes
during this dire moment the entire month
of august we're doing a special adoption
promotion where adult dogs and cats are
fee wave
the animal foundation is taking in a
hundred or more new animals every other
day add to that the two thousand animal
intake over the fourth of july holiday
which has pushed the facility to near
capacity she's just going to have to get
used to us today the answer family says
they found their perfect pet and the
waived adoption fees is a deal too good
to pass up very important they're like
another family member
well the animal foundation is looking to
get all of their pets adopted but
remember you can also help by fostering
you can see how the process works and
how to get started on eight newsnow dot
com
during that story i told christian they
should have got two dogs
to keep them company